[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا
الكرام لماذا تاهب العالم لمواجهه تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه مع العلم انها لم تقترف
واحدا في المليون من جرائم بشار
الاسد اليس ارهاب داعش مجرد لعب عيال
مقارنه بما فعله بشار الاسد بالسوريين على
مدى
سنوات الا تعترف الامم المتحده نفسها بان
الكارثه السوريه هي الاسوا منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بفضل القياده الارهابيه
في دمشق الا تقول امريكا ان بشار الاسد هو
الوجه الاخر لداعش وهو من ساهم
بصناعتها فلماذا اذا تستهدف المصنوعه
وتتركون الصانع لماذا يستهدفون التنظيمات
السنيه ويتغاضى عن الميليشيات الشيعيه
التي تعيث ارهابا في اليمن وسوريا ولبنان
والعراق ما الفرق بين البغداد وقاده
العصابات الشيعيه هل الارهاب السني حرام
والارهاب الشيعي والعلوي حلال يتساءل
احدهم لماذا حرام على ابي بكر البغدادي ما
هو حلال لابي اسد
القرداحي هل ثار الشعب السوري اصلا على
داعش ام على ارهاب ال الاسد في المقام
الاول لكن في المقابل الا تشكل داعش
واخواتها خطرا على كل دول المنطقه والعالم
اليس من الخطر مقارنه استراتيجيه النظام
السوري باستراتيجيه داعش الا يدافع النظام
عن بلده في وجه شذاذ الافاق الذين اجتاحوا
الارض السوريه من كل حدب وصوب الا يعتبر
الاجتياح الداعشي للعراق وسوريا غزوا يجب
التصدي له بكل الوسائل الا تسيطر داعش
الان على منطقه تعادل ضعف مساحه سوريا الم
يكن الرئيس السوري على حق عندما حذر
العالم من خطر تلك التنظيمات منذ بدايه
حداث في
سوريا اليس وقوف العالم الان في وجه داعش
اعترافا متاخرا لابل تاييدا لموقف الحكومه
السوريه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
على الكاتب والاعلامي السوري ثائر الناشف
وعلى الناشط والاعلامي العراقي يزن مشعان
الجبوري نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه من الاكثر اجراما وارهاب
ويستحق عقابا
دوليا تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه ام النظام
السوري النظام
السوري
97.1 تنظيم الدوله
2.9 لو بدات معك بهذه
النتيجه كيف ترد على هذه النتيجه السواد
الاعظم من المصوتين
يعتقدون ان الاولى نعم
بالعقاب هو نظام بشار الاسد وليس تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه بدايه لابد لي من الوقوف
عند ضحايا وشهداء المحرقه السنيه نعم
المحرقه السنيه فادعو المشاهدين جميعا
بدون ل دقيقه صمت وقراءه الفاتحه عليهم
نعم وهذا يؤكد ان ما يجري في سوريا اليوم
وفي العراق ايضا وفي لبنان هي محرقه سنيه
لا تقل بشاعه عن المحرقه الهولوكوست
ومحرقه اوفيتش بحق اليهود فهؤلاء بشر
وهؤلاء بشر من حقهم ان يعيشوا وهذا يؤكد
ان نظام الاسد اشد اجراما من كل الانظمه
التي عرفتها البشريه من من رمسيس الثاني
حتى رمسيس الثاني لم يرتكب جرائم كالتي
ارتكب بشار الاسد اذكرك واذكر المشاهدين
رمسيس الثاني امر جيشه الفرعوني ان يقتل
كل طفل بعد ان
انباه المنجمون والسحره ان هناك طفل سوف
يولد وسوف يصبح نبيا ل يهدم عرشك وملكك
فامر بقتل كل طفل ذكر وترك الاناث بشار
الاسد اليوم يقتل الذكور والاناث اطفالا
شبابا صغارا اذا هو تعدى فرعون فرعون ادعى
الربوبيه بشار الاسد ايضا ادعاها وهو تعدى
هتلر هتلر حرق اليهود في افران بشار الاسد
حرق كل السوريين يعني الشعب السوري بكل
اطيافه وركز على السنه تحديدا بحرقهم حرقا
كاملا تهجير تشريد يعني هتلر ما هجر
اليهود مثل ما يفعل بشار الاسد اليوم
اليوم بشار الاسد هجر الشعب السوري وقتل
من الشعب السوري ما قتل لما لم يفعله
مسليني او نيرون او فرانكو او تشارلز
تايلر او كل او بول بوت او كل هؤلاء
الطغاه التي الذين عرفتهم البشريه فهذا
يعني ان الكل يجمع على انه لابد من عقاب
هذه العصابه النصيريه العلويه ام التي ات
العصابه شو العصابه النصيريه حتى اني ابرا
ان اسميها العلويه لان سيدنا علي بن ابي
طالب رضي الله عنه وارضاه لا يحق لهؤلاء
ان يحملون اسمه هو ارفع من ان يحمل اسمه
وهذه التسميه صحيحه ونعود الى مراجع
التاريخ وهو نسبه الى محمد بن نصير
النميري وهناك مؤلفين يين يعني مشان لا لا
لانه في فرق لانه الان قد ينط لك واحد
يقول لك هذا الناشف طائفي يا اخي ه مش
طائفي انا بسمي الاشياء بمسمياتها انا
اقول نصير و هم يعلمون بذلك ويتحسس من ذلك
ولكنها عصابه احترفت القتل والاجرام اكثر
من كل من عرفته البشريه يعني داعش لعب
عيال كما يرى التصويت داعش لعب عيال ولا
شيء امام نظام الاسد المجرم ولكن انا اريد
ان اعطيك بلغه الارقام حتى لا يكون كلامنا
هكذا على عوان باختصار الشبكه السوريه
لحقوق الانسان وام نستي انترناشونال العفو
الدوليه وثقوا للامم المتحده يرسلون
تقارير الامم المتحده في شهر نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني بلغ عدد الشهداء السوريين
الذين سقطوا على يد نظام الاسد 1170 قتيل
تمام الذين قتلتهم داعش من المدنيين 107
قتله عدد المجازر اللي ارتكبها نظام الاسد
في شهر نوفمبر تشرين الثاني 33 مجزره
مجازر داعش في سوريا مجزره واحده طيب عدد
التدمير المنشات الحيويه مدارس مساجد
طرقات محطات مياه كهرباء ما شئت 58 منشاه
النظام دمر 36 منشاه داعش دمرت منشاتين
يعني فرق اخي بين السماء والارض بين اجرام
هذه العصابه
النصيريه لا اقول انها العلويه النصيريه
الهمجيه البربريه وما فعلته بالشعب السوري
قتلا وتنكيت وبالسنه تحديدا نعم السنه لان
السنه اليوم مستهدفون اخي في سوريا وفي
لبنان في العراق يعني السنه بالعراق اتوا
عليهم
بالمثابرة كيف ترد على هذا الكلام باختصار
شديد يعني هناك اجماع بالرغم من كل
الشيطنه الاعلاميه العربيه والدوليه
لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه واظهاره بانه
يعني ابشع تنظيم ارهابي عرفه التاريخ الا
ان الشارع لا يصدق كل هذه التراهات ويعتقد
انها شيطنه مفضوحه والان من الاكثر اجراما
وارهاب ويستحق عقابا دوليا 97% يعتقدون ان
بشار الاسد هو الاولى بهذا العقاب الدولي
وقصف الدولي وليس داعش كيف ت 97% من
مشاهدي الجزيره مو من الشارع هي اولا يعني
ثانيا انا بدي بين تحفظي على عنوان الحلقه
وعلى طريقه الطرح الم يعني متحيزه جدا
المقارنه بين داعش والنظام السوري غير
مقبوله ابدا طيب وحده عصابه اجراميه
ظلاميه همجيه خارجه عن القانون مجرد
عصابات ونظام سياسي عنده قاعده جماهيريه
رضوا العالم ولا ما رضوا معترف به من
المجتمع الدولي عضو في امم متحده ف
المقارنه بين الاثنين غير مقبوله مثل
المقارنه بين العاهره ورجل الدين مجرد
المقاب المقارنه فيها اساءه فهي غير
مقبوله ابدا داعش عصابه مجرمه باغيه تقتل
مو بس مو تقتل فقط الشيعه ولا ولا هي ضد
الشي ولا هي خلينا نقول تمثل اهل السنه هي
تبدا عند تبدا بسياسه مقاتله الاقرب ا
وهذا مذكور في في ك في كذا كتاب طيب مذكور
مثلا في كتاب العمده في اعداد عده وفي
كتاب العدو القريب هي تعتبر انه وجود قتال
المسيحي الامريكي اولى من قتال المشركين
بعدين بتقول لك قتال الشيعه اولى من قتال
النصارى وقتال السنه من يخالفون بالراي هي
اولى من قتال الشيعه فهي فئه باغيه تقتل
الجميع غير معنيه بهموم السنه بدها تحكم
بدها تنفذ
اجندتها اللي هي شايفتها صح في هذه
المناطق اها في موضوع مين اللي صنعها اذا
بدنا نروح على الصنيعه ام من صنع داعش في
المنطقه بالتاكيد مو النظام السوري في
واحد بالدنيا بيروح بيصنع شيء ليقاتله
يعني مان منطقيه القصه الذي صنع داعش هي
هي الدول التي سهلت عبورهم اللي مدتهم
بالسلاح اللي مدتهم بالمال هذه الدول هي
اللي هي اللي هي صنعت داعش وهي اليوم اللي
راح تحارب داعش هي اللي راح تصير جزء من
التحالف الدولي مو من منطلق مو من منطلق
انه هي ضد داعش ولكن داعش كان فقر تجارب
تحول الى غول هذا الغول ما عاد في في حدا
فينه يضبطه فهم مجبورين من عقده الذنب
وشعور بالمسؤوليه لانه هم صنعوه هذا الخطر
جاي لعندهم رح يقاتلوه بشار الاسد يقاتل
داعش من منطلق مختلف تماما يقاتل داعش
لانه داعش لو كانت تمكنت من اسقاط الرئيس
بشار الاسد في بدايه الازمه لمسحت هي
بدايه الازمه اصلا انت تعلم سيدي ان
الارهاب في سوريا انا اصدقك ولا اصدق
فاروق الشرع فاروق الشرع في مقابله مع
صحيفه الاخبار التابعه لحزب الله نعم قال
بالحرف الواحد نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
السوريه قال بالحرف الواحد قال حتى الشهر
السادس من الثوره السوريه كانت القياده
السوريه تتوسل ان ترى سوريا واحدا يحمل
سكينا فما بالك فما بالك باروده او بندقيه
يعني الشعب السوري لم يحمل سلاح لم يلجا
الى السلاح دقيقه لم يكن هناك اي ارهاب من
الذي فجر الارهاب في سوريا من الذي بدا
الارهاب في سوريا الجيش السور سي
المخابرات السوريه هي التي فتحت الابواب
على كل مصاريعها لبدء الارهاب في سوريا
لماذا لانه هذه هي الطريقه الوحيده كي
تنجو منها تحويل سوريا الى حقل يتحارب فيه
الجميع ما بيخلق بيوم وليله الارهاب في له
مستلزمات لتصير في عن في طريقه للحشد
لطريقه انه كيف بده يمرق لطريقه التوجيهات
كيف بدها تطلع التمويل السلاح هذا كله
بياكل وقت مو بتبلش الازمه في سوريا ثاني
يوم رح يطلع عننا قاعده وتنظيمات متطرفه
مسلحه انت احكي لي اليوم على الارض اللي
موجود المسيطر كطرف معارض للنظام السوري
فقط داعش ما عم نشوف حدا ثاني ما حدا ثاني
له صوت ما حدا ثاني موجود واللي بدرع هذول
والذين حرروا القنيطره ودرعه واصبحوا كذا
جيش حر من الذي يقاتل في ريف دمشق من الذي
يسيطر على دريا من الذي يسيطر على الغوطه
الشرقيه داعش داعش لم تدخل دمشق لم تدخل
دمشق لم تدخل دمشق لم تدخل دم يا سيدي لا
يزن هلا خلينا يعني ما نط فوق الحيطان
كثير داعش مش موجوده بكل المنطقه نن نحن
عم نقارن بين داعش وبين النظام السوري نحن
ما عم نحكي على عم نحكي لا على جيش حر ولا
على معارضه مو هذا موضوعنا ما عم نحكي في
حققيه المعارضه ولا عدم حققيه المعارضه
انا عم بحكي على وجود داعش في سوريا طيب
داعش في سوريا انت عم تقول صنيعه نظام لا
يعني البعض يقولون السؤال مطروح باختصار
كي يعني برايك انه الاولى بالعقاب
وبملاحظة
اكيد بالتاكيد هذا التنظيم الارهابي اللي
اليوم اليوم يمتلك مساحه اكبر من دول
خليجيه كثيره يمتلك من السلاح بناء على
التقارير الامريكيه ما يعادل بحدود 4.7
مليار دولار من السلاح هذا هذا التنظيم
اللي اللي لا يؤمن بالاخر ويؤمن بالغاء
الاخر عن طريق القتل اكيد بالتاكيد هو
اللي اوجب قتاله هي عصابات مسلحه وهذا
نظام اصلا لا يحق لاي احد ان يتدخل في
سوريا بهي الطريقه اللي بده يتدخل فيها ضد
داعش لانه هذا نظام سياسي في عندك قوانين
بتمنع انه هذا الشيء يصير جميل جدا كيف
ترد على هذا الكلام يعني لماذا التقليل من
خطوره هذا التنظيم الرجل قال اصلا من
الخطا ان نقارن نظاما سياسيا لديه شعب
ولديه اقليم ولديه دوله بتنظيم خارج عن كل
قوانين الدنيا ماشي كيف نقارن ذلك هذا هو
السؤال المطروح الاولى بالعالم ان يتصدى
لهذا التنظيم والعالم ولو جاء متاخرا لكنه
يفعل الشيء المضبوط الان كيف ترد اذا كانت
داعش تنظيم ف الاسد عصابه وهناك فرق ما
بين التنظيم والعصابه وهذه عصابه عمرها
يزيد عن 50 عاما لها سجل طويل في الجرائم
قتل ذبح تعذيب داعش يعني اذا امنا انها
ولدت فعلا عمرها سنه ونصف يعني لا اكثر
ولا اقل ثم ان هناك كما تقولون للارهاب
اسباب ومسببات لقد اخطا الكثير من
الباحثين الذين قالوا ان اسباب الارهاب هي
الفقر والجهل والمرض والتخلف بما معناه
الامراض الاجتماعيه كما قال كارين كما
قالت كارين ارمسترونج وفريد هاليدي باحثين
كبار يعني كتبوا في هذه
القضايا اذا اذا اردنا ان نقول عندما تثور
الشعوب وعندما تنتفض وعندما تجعل حياه
طغات جحيما فان ذلك هو بسبب القهر والظلم
اليوم السنه في سوريا وفي العراق وفي
لبنان في هذه الدول واليمن تلحقهم الان
عندما يداس على ترا السنه لكن اثار
الشريعه في اليمن يعني الشباب مش مقصرين
كمان يعني بلشوا انا بقول لك دكتور فيصل
في مقدمات تؤدي واسباب تؤدي الى نتاج
انصار الشريعه نعم انصار الشريعه جماعه
الحوثي هؤلاء نعم لا انصار الله انصار
الله جماعه نعم يعني يعني بنهايه الحديث
هذا حتى نكون دقيقين فيه انه ما دام استمر
ظلم السنه في سوريا وفي العراق فانهم لن
يستطيعوا القضاء على داعش وعلى فكره
الامريكان بما فيهم هم صرحوا وقالوا ان
نظام الاسد هو العدو الاول وهو مصدر الب
انا اعطيك تصريحات يا اخي مشان ما بتحليل
طيب نائب مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي من
شهر صرح وقال ان نظام الاسد هو مصدر
الارهاب الوحيد في المنطقه
و فابيوس لوران فابيوس وزير خارجيه فرنسا
في حديث له مع اذاعه فرانس انفو قال فيه
ان عدونا الاول هو بشار الاسد وهو مصدر
الارهاب ثم الدوله الاسلاميه هي العدو
الثاني لاحظ ايضا تاتي الى تصريحات
مسؤولين اخرين فيليب وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه قال ان نظام الاسد هو المصدر
الاول والوحيد للارهاب في تصريحات ايضا
حديثه له هذا عدا عن تصريحات اردوغان
وسعود الفيصل وامير دوله قطر لانه هؤلاء
يحسبون على انهم من صنع الارهاب لانه الان
شو بيقولوا لك بول لك والله هم اللي صنعوا
داعش ودعموا داعش وغذ داعش لكن ما شافوا
المشكله واسباب المشكله انه وبنفس الوقت
بيعطوا لك تعريفات كبيره لداعش بقول لك
داعش هي تنظيم ارهابي متطرف بعد شوي بقول
لك داعش هي القياده القوميه الجيش العراقي
السابق الدوله العميقه ح حزب البعث المنحل
بعد شوي بقول لك داعش جماعات ارهابيه
وهابيه تكفيريه بعد شوي بقول لك داعش هي
مخابرات ايرانيه صفويه مجوسيه ويعني شتتوا
الامور يعني بامكان اي مسؤول عربي يطلع
وياخذ معلومات ويبرزها للاعلام انه داعش
كذا وكذا وكذا هذه هي حقيقه داعش يعني اذا
ارادوا ان يوضحوا للراي العام يتفضلوا
يوضحوا لكن هذا الغموض البناء الذي تعتمده
الاداره الامريكيه الان فيما يعرف بسياسه
الفوضى الخلاقه سوف ياتون الى السنه في
سوريا والعراق عاجلا ام اجلا وتذكر كلامي
يا دكتور فيصل دمسي رئيس اركان الجيوش
الامريكيه المشتركه قال لن نهزم داعش وعلى
فكره داعش خرافه هم صنعوها بالمناسبه الا
عندما نعود الى السنه بمعنى انه جايين على
السنه جايين لانه داعش يعني هن اصلا لا
يستطيعون الاعتماد على الشيعه ولا
الاعتماد على النصيريه حتى يحاربوا هؤلاء
لا يستطيعون ان يحاربوا هؤلاء بامكانهم ان
يقتلوا وانا حتى يعني اوضح لك وبامكان
الساده المشاهدين ان يعلموا ما يحك ويدبر
يعني في كتاب مهم جدا وهو ممنوع بالمناسبه
بسوريا الكتاب هذا الاسلام وخرافه
المواجهه يقول في ريد هاليدي باختصار بس
والله ضروري لانه هذا بعد ما اقرا يمكن
الحلقه تنتهي على فكره يقول مفهوم الخطر
الاسلامي هو ذاته خرافه والحديث عن نزاع
مستمر عبر التاريخ بين العالم الاسلامي
والعالم الغربي هراء تصور فمن الجانب
الاسلامي من الحماقه ان نرى البلدان
الاسلاميه وكانها بمعنى ما تهدد الغرب فقد
اختفى منذ امد طويل الخطر العسكري الذي
يثيره الاسلام والقوات الاسلاميه منذ ان
سقطت الدوله العثمانيه لم يعد للمسلمين
قائمه يا اخي اي خلافه انت عم تحكي لي
عنها عن داعش يعني برايك مصدق انه فعلا في
خلافه يا اخي هذول الشباب تقوللك داعش
خليني افصصلك افصصلك داعش دكتور ثانيه
داعش من هي خ 70% من المقاتلين الاجانب
والعرب اللي ههم ليسوا عراقيين وسوريين
لانه في داعش سوري وفي داعش عراقي هؤلاء
اتوا لنصره السنه هلا تم تجنيدهم تطويع
بمشروع ما 30% من يؤمنون بالخلافه فقط
يعني يعني اوروبا لما صارت فيها مجازر ما
هبت اوروبا المسيحيه كلها لنصره المسيحيين
الذين قتلوا هنام جدا جميل جدا خليني ارجع
لنقطه مهمه جدا الى معايير المعايير
الدوليه يعني السؤال الذي يطرحه الكثيرون
ما هي المعايير التي يقيس عليها المجتمع
الدولي او الغرب مدى قوه الارهاب وتاليا
ما هي اليه التصنيف ماشي نعم عدد القتلى
اذا اعتبرنا ان المعيار الاساسي الذي
اعتبره اعتبره الغرب لتصنيف قوه الارهاب
هو عدد الضحايا فنح فنحن امام معضله كبيره
لاننا اذا ما حسبنا عدد الناس الذي قتلهم
النظام العلوي سنجده يزيد باضعاف على عدد
الناس الين قتل
داشم التقير هذا تقرير موثق كاملا بس
دقيقه
دقيقه اخي النظام السوري هذ حطنا بالغلط
ماشي كيفيات القتل كيفيات القتل ما شاء
الله اللي بيحكم بسوريا السنه مش هيك
ه دقيقه كيفيه القتل اذا اعتبرنا ان
المعيار الاساسي هو كيفيه القتل فثم عشرات
الفيديوهات لارهاب النظام قطع رؤوس سلخ
جلد دفن ناس احياء من الذي بدا بعمليات
الذبح في سوريا لماذا الجميع يركز على
عمليات الذبح بتاع داعش من الذي بدا اول
عمليه ذبح في سوريا من الذي ذبح المطرب
الحموي الشهير القاشوش ورمى بحنجرته في
نهر العاصي اليس مخابرات الاسد بس دقيقه
لا انا عم يا اخي
دقيقه خلين اكملك خليني اكمل لك عن الذبح
عن الذبح عن موضوع الذبح من الذي ذبح
السوريين في مذبحه الترمسي في مذبحه
الحوله في كل المذابح بسوريا طيب ما انتم
عم تحكي انه هذه الداعش النظام ارهابي
عنيف لم يسبق له مثيل اذا نظرنا اذا قارنا
بالاسد كل انواع الاجرام هو الذي بداها في
سوريا كيف ترد وبدي ارجع لك تفضل دكتور
اولا داعش داعش داعش لم تخلق في
سوريا هي امتداد لتنظيم القاعده اسمحلي هي
امتداد لتنظيم القاعده تنظيم القاعده هو
اول من بدا بالتفجيرات والقتل والعراق طيب
هو الوح
هو حال واحده عار زن ز بدي اسالك انا بس
بدي احطك انه المعايير نحن مش معايير انه
لماذا استهداف داعش وترك الاسد مش عمليه
ارهاب نقارن الارهابين ادوات القتل ادوات
القتل لدى النظام التي استعملها حتى
سكاكين المطابخ استخدمها استخدم صواريخ
اسكود استخدم الكيماوي ماذا استخدم الداعش
بالمقابل لا ندافع عنها لا احد يدافع عنها
لكن السؤال المطروح الان لماذا هب العالم
لمواجهه تنظيم لم يمارس واحد على مليار من
اجرام ال الاسد والعلويين كيف ترد انت
لساتك مصر على هال هيكك مصر على انشوف
الارهاب العلوي يا زلمه انت لانك ما عم
اشوف الارهاب العلوي انا عم اشوف رئيس
سوري يدافع عن بلده ضد فئه ارهابيه مجرمه
هذا اللي انا عم اشوفه انت شايف هيك مش
سؤلات من الناس عم يسالوها انا عم بسالك
اها سؤالات الناس هدول الناس شايفين هي
وجهه النظر انا شايف وجهه نظر مختلفه انا
شايف رئيس بنظام شرعي موجود ببلد يدافع عن
ارضه ضد فئه باغيه اسمها داعش بده يذبحهم
زتم بالاسيد يضربهم بسكود هو عم يقاتلوه
على ارضه واحد قاعد عد بارضه اجت فئه من
كل الكره الارضيه مدعومه من حواضن من كل
المجتمع اللي داير ما دايره من الخليج
اجوا اليوم عم يقاتلوا الرئيس الاسد في
لده شو المفروض يعمل شو يزت عليهم من
الطبيعي ان يقتل من الطبيعي ان يقاتل ضده
من الطبيعي ان يق خ خ شوي كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام انتم دق
حبي هذا النظام يقول لك الرجل من حقه ان
يفعل الافاعيل هو يدافع عن وطن هو يواجه
اكبر الحملات الارهابيه في التاريخ كيف
ترد يواجه وطن ويحرق يعني ها الطفله في في
بلده راس النبع حرقوها يعني تصوروا يعني
داعش يعني داعش في شغله مهمه جدا يا جماعه
الخير داعش يا اخي قتلت من الشعيطات ومن
البونمر ومن البو علوان تمام من البو فهد
في العراق وسوريا يعني بس يا اخي بتقتل
رجال العصابه النصيريه تقتل اطفال الله
اكبر يا اخي معقول لك فيهم هذول قلب وفيهم
رحمه انهم يذبحوا طفل تصور يعني لا يقارن
الاجرام دكتور يعني داعش لا يقارن اجرام
داعش طبعا لانه داعش انا ما شفت انا ما
تجيبوا لي داعش قتلت او ذبحت طفل عمره سنه
او سنتين ما في يا اخي صيه عملوها اعوذ
بالله بدوها القاشوش وقبل القاشوش طبعا ما
بنحكي عن ثمانينات هذا ما نسينا على فكره
بعطيك امثله ماذا عن الص يا اخي عن
الصحفيين
قطيني تريمس وبعدين الصحفي تريمس والحوله
ذبحوا الاطفال دخلوا عليهم وهي الصور يعني
هي الصور مشان ما ما تكذب نفسها هي براس
النبع وبعدين في شعار مهم جدا طرحوا ما
خرجوا على نفسهم الاسد او نحرق البلد بدنا
نبيد السنه تمام وهي اكثر من 11000 قتيل
قتلوهم بسجون التعذيب يا بدا كل واحد منهم
هيكل عظمي وموثقه في الكونغرس وفي محكمه
العدل الدوليه في لاهاي وهذه الصور التي
تسربت ولا وشو راحت على الكونجرس وما
عملوا شي يعني ما بدهم يحاسبوه ما بدهم
يوجهوا له ضربات او يتم يا اخي ما بدنا
يضربوه ضرب صاروخي بس يحولوه على المحكمه
الدوليه ما في تحويل على المحكمه الد
عصابه نصير محميه من النظام العالمي
الجديد نعم انا هكذا اسميه وهكذا هي
مهمتها تدمير سوريا وتفتيتها وقتل السنه
وتشريد السنه وتحقيق معادله ان السنه في
سوريا سيصبح اقليه فيما بعد خمس سنوات او
ست سنوات والى ما هنالك من مخططات
ومؤامرات تحاك وتدبر رغم ان في سوريا
ليسوا بطائف انا قلت ه بس بس ب اسالك سؤال
طيب عندما يقول مثلا انت يعني هناك نوع من
التناقض الغرب يقول انه داعش هي الوجه
الاخر لبشار الاسد طيب السؤال اللي بسالك
اياه لماذا اذا يستهدفون المصنوع ويتركون
الصانع هذا هو السؤال لان داعش كما قلت لك
هي خرافه وهذا الكتاب واضح يعني هذا من
اهم ما كتب عن الارهاب باقلام غربيين يعني
هذا استاذ في جامعه لندن يعني ل ماذا تريد
اكثر من ذلك لانهم يصنعون لانه في شيء
دكتور فيصل الاقتصاد العالمي لا يستطيع ان
يستمر بمستوياته العاليه دون ان يكون هناك
خطر خلقوا الخطر الشيوعي الخطر الاحمر ثم
الخطر الاصفر الصين الان يقومون يعني هذا
كله يتم الان تجهيزه في في قنوات ووسائل
اعلام ومحطات راي عام حتى يكون هناك بعبع
يعني تعطيك مثال تعطيك مثال خ باختصار
عندما قتل جيمس فولي الصحفي الامريكي وانا
ادي ل هذا القتل وهو زميل لنا قامت الدنيا
ولم تقعد عندما قتلته داعش نعم بيتر كاسيك
نفس الشيء عامل الاغاثه وديفيد هانين ماذا
عن ماري كولفن يا جماعه الخير ماري كولفن
ماري كولفن والصحفيه اليابانيه مايومي هذه
هي ماري كولفن جيل جاكيه ريمي او شليك كل
هذول هذول شو هذول هذول عباره عن لحم فسيخ
معفن اما جيمز فولي دمه ازرق قامت الدنيا
وما قعدت طيب يا اخي هذا الصحفي الصحفي
امريكيه نعم امريكيه طيب يعني ليش ما تحرك
العالم على مقتلها في بابا عمر وكذلك
الامر على جيل جاكيه المصور الفرنسي طيب
ماشي ليش ما تحرك العالم على تامر العوام
ابن محافظه السويده والالماني هو مخرج
سينمائي الماني انقتل بالحي الاذاعه بحلب
والله ولا حدا سال فيه ولا حدا سمع عنه
خبر ولا حس معقول امبارح النظام قتل ثلاث
مراسلين لقناه الاورينت يعني وهم زملاء
لنا وقتل صحفيين مراسلكم يا اخي محمد
المسالمه من درعا ما قتل مراسل الجزيره
طيب وين يعني يعني يعني الان معناتها بهذا
بموجب ذلك تستطيع الان دوله قطر ان تقصف
نظام الاسد مثل ما تفعل اميريكا اللي هي
عم تقصف داعش بامكان اي دوله انقتل لها
صحفي تقصف هذا النظام المجرم يعني الرد
بالرد فبالتالي لا يقارن يعني وبنفس الوقت
هناك عمليه تضخيم ونفخ نفخ في قربه مثقوبه
شيء اسمه داعش والتغاضي عن
لب المشكله الحقيقيه وهي هذه العصابه
النصيريه الصفويه المجوسيه التي فتكت قتلا
[موسيقى]
وتعذيباً كيف ترد على هذا الكلام البعض
يقول انه استهداف داعش او استهداف تنظيم
الدوله من قبل الاسره الدوليه او العالم
يعود الى انه يعني امريكا
واسرائيل اذا ارادت ان تكافئ بشار الاسد
يمكن ان تبني له تماثيل من ذهب في كل
المدن لان الذي حققه لها من دمار في سوريا
والمنطقه لا يمكن لا لاسرائيل بربك لو
شارون جاء الى سوريا هل يدمر 10% من الذي
دمره هذا النظام الطائفي في سوريا يتساءل
الكثيرون السؤال المطروح امريكا سعيده
بهذا النظام سعيده ببشار الاسد حتى في اخر
مؤتمر في اوروبا قالوا لماذا لا تتخلص منه
قال كيف نتخلص منه هذا هو قائد الفوضى
الهلاك في المنطقه المنطقه كلها على كف
عفريت بسبب هذا المغناطيس يجذب كل اشرار
العالم الى المنطقه اذا هو عباره عن اداه
لهذا لا يقصفون اما التنظيمات الاسلاميه
فيجب ان تقصف حتى لو مارست واحد بالمليون
مما اقترفه هذا المجرم هكذا يقولون كيف
فترد يعني اولا من يجذب الاشرار لمقاتلته
بالتاكيد م انه شرير يعني هي اولا ثانيا
ما يثبت صحه موقف بشار الاسد والمتحالفين
مع بشار الاسد هو اصلا قدوم التحالف
الدولي الان لمقاتله داعش هو اثبات لصحه
موقف بشار الاسد وانه فعلا يقاتل ارهاب في
سوريا جميل واحد اثنين انت قطعتني لو داعش
مكنت من انها تدخل دمشق
لسبت الدروس والعلويه والشيعه ول ذبحت
السنه ول كتبت نون كبيره على دمشق القديمه
مثل ما فعلت بالموصل بس دقيقه شوي بس
خليني اسالك يا رجل نعم انت عم تحكي لو
ولو ولو طيب ما انا عندي على الارض الامم
المتحده بالامس وصفت سوريا بانها الكارثه
الابشع منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وفيق
الناصر رئيس الامن العسكري في المنطقه
الجنوبيه مارس كل انواع الاغتصاب مارس كل
انواع السرقه ضابط مخابرات هذا بالتقرير
يا اخي كل الناس تعرفه
وال هذا هذا المجرم هذا المجرم انا بعطيك
مثال بسيط والله داعش بد الف سنه لتعمل
اللي عمله وفيق الناصر من سرقه اثار من
تجاره بالمخدرات من تجاره بالمازوت لم
يترك مهنه الا مارسها الامن العسكري
في في المنطقه الجنوبيه شو داعش وشو ماعش
يا زلمه هذا الكلام انت هذا سؤال بترجع
بتقول لي لو دخلت ولو دخلت يا رجل من الذي
قصف السوريين بالكيماوي 12 مليون سوري
مهجر من الذي هجره انا اللي هجرتهم متى
ظهرت داعش متى ظهرت داعش الشعب السوري
السبب في تهجيرهم وقتلهم هم من تامر على
سوريا مو سوريا بدي اسالك عندما ثار الشعب
السوري عندما خرج الحمويين اكثر من مليون
واحد عندما ثارت حمص عندما ثارت درعه هل
ثارت ضد داعش ولا ثارت ضد نظام المخابرات
لماذا نسينا اصل الثوره وكله حاطينه الان
بداعش وبالنصر داعش والنصره لماذا لا نعود
الى اصل المشكله من اصل المشكله لماذا ثار
الشعب السوري بالمقام الاول جاوبني نحن مو
موضوعنا اللي ثار الشعب السوري نحن
موضوعنا اليوم هنالك حرب اليوم اللي موجود
على الارض هو حرب بين النظام السوري وداعش
هذا اللي موجود على الارض اليوم ما في لا
مظاهره ولا معارضين تحول الفيلم كله الى
مقاتله بين النظام وبين
داعش من تامروا على سوريا حاولوا اسقاط
النظام بكذا طريقه لم تنجح ولا طريقه
الطريقه الامثل لاسقاط النظام بالنسبه لهم
كانت هي داعش النظام السوري قاتل داعش
لمده ثلاث سنوات وشوي يقاتل التنظيمات
المتطرفه المسلحه في سوريا هل ثلاث سنين
وشوي سوريا لوحدها مع حلفائها النيين
وداعش مع حلفاء الخفيين ا تقاتلوا على
الارض السوريه ولم تستطيع تتمكن داعش من
اسقاط هذا النظام اليوم التحالف الدولي
كله اكتشف انه هي داعش و عم برجع انا بعيد
نفس الكلام مره ثانيه اكتشف انه داعش غول
لا يمكن التحكم به فراحوا التحالف الدولي
لضرب داعش هذا دليل دليل دليل منطقي ولاني
على انه بشار الاسد موقفه صحيح من مقاتله
الارها طيب هذه نقطه مهمه انا بدي اسالك
طيب الم يكن النظام السوري وعلى راسه بشار
الاسد محقا ومصيب عندما حذر العالم منذ
سنوات قال لهم انظروا الارهاب ثم الارهاب
ثم الارهاب عليكم بهذه الجماعات لم يعره
احد اي اهتمام الان هل تستطيع ان تركر ان
النظام
السوري استطاع ولو متاخرا باقناع العالم
بان هناك مشكله ارهاب وبان القصف الامريكي
وقصف التحالف لداعش هو تاييد لمقوله
الحكومه السوريه ليس تاييدا لان زعماء في
الغرب يعني كلوران فابيوس قالها صراحه ان
بشار الاسد هو عدونا الاول لكن هي القضيه
كلها هي محاوله من زعماء الغرب شحد انظار
الراي العام هم اللي لديهم شعوب دكتور
فيصل الغرب يريدون دائما ان يخفونه
ببعبدا اما يكون الاسلام هو
الفزاعه التي يتم استثاره الراي العام
فيها حتى تتعلق امور اقتصاديه وغير ذلك لا
نريد الدخول فيها لذلك كله بشار الاسد هو
منبع ومصدر الارهاب اليوم اذا بدنا نعرف
الارهاب ما هو الارهاب الارهاب هو ان تقتل
كرامه شعب باكمله اليوم الشعب السوري اليس
ما يجري عليه هو ارهاب يعني ايضا علينا ما
ننسى دكتور فيصل انه حلفاء النظام الاسد
المجرم هذا كلهم ارهابيون وكلهم رهط من
الارهاب مارسوا الارهاب بابشع اشكاله من
ايران الى ما هنالك من ميليشيات شيعيه
صفويه تقاتل مع نظام الاسد بالمناسبه انا
بالنسبه لي عصابه الاسد انتهت ما ظل في
شيء اسمه عصابه اذا بدكم تسموها نظام انا
ما بسميه نظام بس انتهى ليش لانه جيشه
انقتل كله يعني اليوم عندك 135000 نصيري
انقتل هي واحد 22000 مفقود منهم اكثر من
200000 جريح ومنهم طبعا حالات يعني اصابه
الطائفه النصيريه في سوريا عددها 3 مليون
اذا بدنا ناخذ نسبه وتناسب معناتها الفئه
العمريه من من 18 لسن ال 40 انقرضت ما ظل
عندهم غير النسوان والاولاد الصغار وال
الشيوخ الكبار يعني يعني بشار الاسد حتى
ورض طائفته وادخلها هذه المتاهه هلا بقول
لك داعش ستذبح وتقتل وكذا طيب جميل جدا
طيب لما صارت معركه الساحل دكتور في كسب
وفي مناطق ك مناطق كمصرف سلم وانا رحت على
فكره رحت على قريه برج القصب برفقه الجيش
الحر والثوار الذين كانوا هناك ومنهم طبعا
مقاتلين الاسلاميين طبعا ليسوا من داعش يا
رجل تصور البيوت الامنين ما هدموها وعلى
فكره بالمناسبه قريه برج الق هي قريه
مسيحيه نصيره ليس فيها سنه لم ذوا كنيسه
دخلت البيوت بيتا بيتا كاسه المتي مروكي
مثل ما هي جيش النصيري اذا بيدخل بيحرق
الاخضر واليابس ما بخلي شيء بيحرق الكبار
والصغار ويسرق كل شيء ويكسر سرقه يعني
تصور تصور يعني حتى داعش يعني انا لا اريد
ان ادافع عن داعش مين داعش انا ماني شايف
داعش تصور حتى البقر بيسرقو يعني بزمانه
يصر عظمه في
مرايا والثاني سرقه الدجاج هي هذا الجيش
دقيقه يعني هذا الجيش المدجج بالدجاج
بالدجاج نعم لانه كانوا يتهموا صالح العلي
نحن نعتبره يعني رمز الثوره السوريه انه
كان عم لم فشك الفرنسيين لكن بالواقع هم
كانوا يسرقوا الدجاج شلاليف يعني شلاليف ك
يا وطن هي الشغله معروفه والبقر على مقوله
ياسر عظمى ان فضله البقر عم بيير وبقر بلش
يطير هلا فاذا ما ظل عنده شيء حتى
الميليشيات الشيعيه الصفويه التي تاتي الى
سوريا اليوم من يقاتل في سوريا عند بشار
الاسد هي الميليشيات الشيعيه وهذه هي يعني
شوف كتيبه السيده زينب بسموها لحم طيب حتى
الثوار خلي لا لا لا دقيقه دي اسال هذا
السؤال خدي اخذ النقطه لسيد يزن سيد يزن
طيب لا باس ان
العالم يقف في وجه كل
من يضر بالارض السوريه او من يقاتل على
الارض السوريه ف فليطه سوريا من كل
الجماعات الموجوده في سوريا لا باس في ذلك
ومن حقهم السؤال الذي يطرحه الكثيرون الان
لماذا الاستهداف فقط للجماعات السنيه دون
غيرها لماذا لا يستهدفون
شو اسمه فصائل او عصائب اهل الباطل او ما
يسموها اهل اهل الحق مثلا اه كم فصيل شيعي
يعيث دمارا وخرابا في لبنان في سوريا في
العراق الان في اليمن هل العصابات الشيعيه
متخرجه من السوربون ومن هارفارد وتنظيم
داعش جاي من تورا بورا من جامعه تورا بورا
مثلا هل الاسلام السني او هل الارهاب
السني اللي عم تمارسه داعش حرام
والارهاب الشيعي حلال هذا هو السؤال الذي
يطرح الان لماذا تقصف داعش وتترك كل
الفصائل الاجراميه والميليشيات الفاشيه
الشيعيه تذبح في سوريا من الذي ذبح اكثر
في سوريا قارن ما فعله جماعه حزب الله
والعصابات الفاشيه الشيعيه في سوريا بما
فعلته داعش لا شيء هكذا هذه كل الدنيا
تعرفها كيف ترد اولا تكلم لك عن اللي
تسميهم انت ميليشيات في العراق هم 17 جهه
ام اسلاميه شيعيه تقاتل تحت مسمى الحشد
الشعبي زائدا عشائر سنيه تقاتل الى جنب هي
اللي بتسميها انت ميليشيات يعني انت اليوم
انت لو هي ميليشيا شيعيه متطرفه لن تسمح
لاحد بالقتال الى جانبها ابدا نحن
بالبيج في تكريت في مكي شيفه قريبا بالشرط
في محافظه صلاح الدين باعتبار المعارك
الان تدور في صلاح الدين العشائر السنيه
تقاتل الى جانب الشيعه لاول مره طبعا كان
اك ازمه ثقه بالبدايه ولكن الان راحت هي
ازمه تقلي
موجوده انتم اليوم تعتبرون ان الذي يقاتل
في سوريا هم فقط العلويين ايه لا لا انا
بس بدي اسالك انت انت سني مش هيك طيب ليش
يا سيدي ما هو الفرق بين البغدادي وحسن
نصر الله ما هو الفرق بين البغدادي ما
الفرق بين البغدادي والخامنئي طيب لماذا
حلال على الشيعه ان يكون لديهم ولايه فقيه
يقولون يا اخي مش انا انا زلمه مش مش مش
مش بتعرفني لا عندي لحي ولا من يحزنون
ماشي ماشي طيب لماذا حلال على هؤلاء لماذا
حلال على هؤلاء ان يقاتلوا في اليمن يقاتل
في لبنان ويقاتل في سوريا ويقاتل في
العراق ويذبح السنه ويذبحوا الجميع
ويعملوا وما حدا جاي صوبهم اما السنه
ارهابيين اقصف اعملوا تحالف اعمل كشه داعش
تمثل
السنه سني لا تمثل داعش لا يفل الحديد الا
الحديد عندك شبيحه عندك شبيحه علويين ف
فمش مشكله يكون في شبيحه دواعش مقابلهم
هكذا
يقولون الحديدي اولا المقارنه بين ابو بكر
البغدادي وسيد حسن نصر الله او خامن الى
اخره عطيني واحد من القياديين الشيعيين
الشيعه عفوا اي واحد من القياديين افتى
بقتل السنه فتوى علنيه بقتل السنه واحد او
حلل دم السنه واحد من
القياديين هي وثيقه مشربه هي مسربه يقول
السيستاني ويقول محمد تقي اليزدي في وثيقه
مسربه عام 2008 يقول فيها وهي طبعا قبلل
احتلال العراق قبل ما تدخل القوات
الامريكيه يقول الله سخر لنا الامريكان
حتى يعود الحق الى اهله ويقولون ان
الامريكان كالثور الهائج في يد الفلاح
ويجب توجيههم لمحاربه النواصب يعني السنه
ثم يقول محمد تق اليزيدي الجهاد الاكبر هو
في القضاء على الرعاع العرب ومذهبهم الضال
واعاده الخلافه المسلوبه الى اهلها يعني
الخلافه الشيعيه بعد غياب دام اكثر من
1400 سنه يعني اليوم عقد مؤتمر في الدوحه
انا ادعو قاده الخليج من الدوحه من هون
يشكلوا ناتو عربي مهمه هذا الناتو يكون
بالبحرين لانه البحرين على فكره لو رايحه
بال 2011 راح ال كله مسح خالص ويكون مهمه
هذا الناتو العربي تمام في الخليج دوال
مجلس الخليج وادعو مصر الى ان تنظم رغم
الخلافات بس دقيقه الرجل قال لا بدي نقطه
ارد عليها قاللك اصلا من العيب ان تقارن
السيد حسن نصر الله المقاوم العظيم
بالبغدادي وهؤلاء الارهابيين كيف ترد كيف
لا نصر الله حسب الشيطان نصر الله
دقيقه
حسن حسن حسن حسن نص ليره او نص فرنك يا
رجل هذا ارتكب ارهاب وارتكب اجرام تعدى ث
بس يقول
لك اقول لك من الخطا المقارنه بين جماعه
داعش والجماعات الشيعيه التي تقاتل هذا هو
السؤال بدون ما شخص يا دكتور يا دكتور
فيصل بالله عليك شوف لي هالصوره هيا هذول
هم الحشد الشعبي اللي سموهم كلاب الشيعه
الصفويين شوف كيف بيقتلوا اهل السنه
بالمثقب يا اخي على فكره العشائر العربيه
السنيه التي تقاتل مع الحشد الشعبي هؤلاء
كلاب السنه وليس السنه في العراق والسنه
في العراق ليسوا داعش هناك شرفاء من و
فكره فكره لا مشان ما يزعل السيد يزن وحتى
السنه اللي عند بشار الاسد هؤلاء كلاب
وسفل السنه وفي ما بدي اذكر لك اسما اذا
بدك حسون او يعني هؤلاء كلاب السنه منك
الكلاب مش موضوع فيعني ما بنحط والله
الدبس او نحط البصل بالرز ونخلط يعني
فبالتالي هؤلاء مجرمون لا احد يعني يتعدى
اجرامهم الميليشيات الشيعيه هي اليوم من
يسند هذا المجرم بشار الاسد ومن تبقى معه
من
هناه ل لسه بقولوا لك شو بقولوا لك ققول
لك قال نحن مذهب فلسفي مين النصيريه كل ما
قتلوه وذبحوا فيه بقول لك نحن مذهب فلسفي
وياتو الشيعه ويقولون لك ان الخامنئي
والسيستاني هو شو هو رب الفكر المعتدل بس
بدي اذكر ملالي خم هؤلاء قبل ان يصبحوا
لديهم ما يسمى ولايه فقيه يعني شلون الغرب
رايك دكتور فيصل يسمح دوله اسلاميه بتسمي
حالها جمهوريه اسلاميه ايرانيه يا رجل
مجرد كلمه اسلامي بدوله مستحيل يعني حتى
الدوله الامويه كان اسمها الدوله الامويه
الدوله العباسيه دوله الخلفاء ما كان في
الدوله الامويه الاسلاميه حتى الدوله
العثمانيه كان اسمها دولتي عاليه عثمانيه
تصور هؤلاء ملال خهم كانوا يقبلون يد
النساء يعني هي فرح ديبه هؤلاء خم ايران
قبلوا يدها حتى يصير عندك شيوخ سنه يقبلوا
ايد النسوان بقت السنه رضى عليهم وممكن
السنه وقتها يحكموا لكن ما دام السنه لهم
راس وكرامه وعزه وحريه نفس بدهم ينداس
وينقل منهم ما ينقتل حتى يصبح هناك فاجعه
كبرى في المنطقه ولكن على السنه ان يعوا
الدرس جيدا انهم عليهم ان لا يثقوا كثيرا
بكل هذه الالعيب والاكاذيب ثم اني بس بدي
ا دقيقه لا لا طيب تفضل تفضل قطعتك انا بس
جاوب عليها من العيب رجع لموضوع تبع السيد
السستاني هو طلع وثيقه مسربه ماشي والسيد
السيستاني على موقعه قصدي وتناولت الاخبار
علانيه قال لا بد للشيعه ان يدافعوا عن
الحقوق الاجتماعيه والسياسيه للسنه قب
لابناء السنه انفسهم خطابنا هو الدعوه الى
الوحده وكنت ولا ازال اقول ولا تقولوا
اخواننا السنه بل قولوا انفسنا اهل السنه
جميل هذا الكلام العلني مو الوثائق
المسربه ابو بكر البغدادي وداعش اللي
المفروض على اساس يمثل السنه مثل الاخ
يمثل سنه الاخ ما يمثلوني انا ابدا يعني
ابو بكر البغدادي يفتي بذبح الشيعه فاتوا
على سبايكر في تكريت ذبحوا 1700 واحد شيعي
ما شفنا استنكار من ولا دوله سنيه من ولا
زعيم سني بسبب هذا السعار الطائفي الذي
يجتاح المنطقه جميل استعار الطائفي اللي
انا بتبرا منه ولا اتشرف اكون معه ونحن
كعشاء سنيه سنقف الى جانب الحشد الشعبي في
تحرير مناطقنا من داعش وبس نخلص من داعش
المنطق يقول يجب ان نتعاون مع الحكومه
السوريه لملاحقه داعش في في داخل سوريا اي
كانوا يتهموا الحكومه السوريه انه هي
بتشرب الارهاب بال 2008 و 2009 ترقيقه
السؤال المطروح البعض يعني انت من دعاه
ملاحقه هذه التنظيمات وضربه وقصفه وكذا
طيب السؤال وابادتها نعم طيب لماذا لماذا
هذا العالم الحقير كما يصفونه العالم
الحقير نعم يشاهد ما حدث لسوريا وللشعب
السوري منذ اربع سنوات يعني لم يحصل في
العالم كارثه مثل الكارثه السوريه الان اه
ماشي طيب لماذا
لمق ماشي لماذا لم يقدم هذا العالم السلاح
للشعب السوري الا بالقطاره وعندما وعندما
ثار عندما ذهبوا الى كوباني وصلت ال
الاسلحه بال الاطنان لمواجهه التنظيمات
الاسلاميه هذا هو السؤال الذي يسالوه
الانون بعلاقات وتحالف ز اخ يزن اخ يزن اخ
يزن هذا سؤال وصلني كثيرا الا تعتقد ان
استهداف داعش والتركيز على داعش وعلى
التنظيمات الاسلاميه السنيه تحديدا وقصفها
وشيطنتها وغض الطرف عما فعله بشار الاسد
وما يفعله او تفعله الميليشيات الشيعيه
هذا سيدفع بمئات الالاف من الشباب السني
الى احضان داعش هذا هو السؤال يا عالم يا
هو انتم تريدون القضاء على داعش فكيف
تغطون الطرف عن الذي اقترف اضعاف ما
اقترفته داعش و وتذهبون الى داعش مئات
الالاف من الشبان سيذهبون الى داعش الان
هل تستطيع ان تنكر ذلك نعم بسبب بسبب هذه
الازدواجيه بسبب الخطاب التحريضي تحريضي
بسبب هذا الخطاب التحريضي بسبب الدعم
اللام محدود اللي راح لهذه الجماعات
والتسهيل ه كيف كيف فاتوا لسور بس فهمني
دكتور نزلوا نزلوا فرش ما اجوا عن طريق
سيا ما طاروا من مطارات اوروبا ما طاروا
من مطارات الامريكي ما طار مطارات ال يزن
يا يزن بس عندما الشباب العربي الذي يرى
كيف حرقت سوريا كيف حرق يحرق العراق كيف
يحرق كذا ويخرج ابو بكر البغدادي ويقول له
انا ساوا بشار الاسد وساوا الشيعه والنصير
ومن هذا الكلام الطائفي البغيض كلنا ضد
هذا الكلام طائفي وعلوي وما بعرف شو هذا
كلام بغم جدا والكل متفق عليه ماشي السؤال
المطروح عندما الشباب يرى ما الذي يحصل
الان هذا الان انت لحظت يا اخي انت عم
بتقول مشاهدين الجزيره يا اخي مشاهدين
الجزيره سميهم ما شئت 97%
يعتقدون اخي 97% من الذين استفتوا من هذه
الشريحه على الاقل تقول ايها العالم يجب
ان تعاقب وتلاحق نظام بشار الاسد وليس
داعش داعش اثنين صوتوا له فقط نعم طيب كيف
ترد يا دكتور 90% من هدول واحد قاعدلي
بالسعوديه ماه جزء من المشكله اللي عم
تصير ماه جزء من الحرب التي تحدث جزء جزء
هذا را عام جزيره م را عام هذا هذاه
استفتاء من عن 100 مليون مشاهد هول
ماك انا
ابداك لازم يكونوا شيعه مشان يقبلوه لازم
يكون
شيعه لا يكون
سم لازم يكونوا سني وشيعه ولازم تكون جهه
محايده لاي استفتاء
بالدني ماشي ماشي استفتا عاه الجزيره انا
اليوم بروح بعمل كمان استفتا على قناه
الاتجاه باخذ 99% ن ل شوف شوف يا يزن انا
لا اختلف معك لا اقول لك انه هذه مضبوطه
100% لكن انا اسالك سؤال منطقي واعيد
السؤال عندما يرى العالم عندما عندما يرى
عندما يرى الشباب العربي ان الشعب السوري
هجرته طائفه هجره نظام نازي فاشي كذا وهذا
العالم لم يفعل شيئا لم يعمل اي شي حتى
بعد ان استخدم الكيماوي بينما هذا العالم
الحقير تجاوز مجلس الامن ولم يسمع لا
لروسيا ولا للفيتو الروسي وذهب وحشد 40
دوله وبدا يقصف بداعش التي لم تفعل شيئا
كما يقولون انا اسالك ابدا اللي حدث ابدا
انا رح اشرح لك كيف ابدا هذا هي هذا الحشد
الدولي والتحالف الدولي هو نفسه اللي ترك
داعش ثلاث سنين تقتل وتذبح في سوريا لغرض
قتال النظام السوري اها الهدف هو تدمير
سوريا اجش ضرب هدول وهدول بيضربوا الجيش
وتصير حرف في داخل سوريا واحد
باختصار لما صارت المشكله في العراق ايضا
التحالف الدولي ما تحرك سقط ثلث العراق
بيد داعش والجماعه قاعدين عم يتفرجوا
علينا عندما اقتربت هذه التنظيمات المسلحه
من كردستان العراق وكردستان تتمتع بعلاقات
استراتيجيه مع دول العالم مو مثل نظام
بغداد تدخل بطريقه سريعه زادت القصه ولكن
اليوم انا لا ارهن على الامريكان ابدا طيب
اليوم اليوم اللي يحدث في العراق انا
اراهن على العراقيين انفسهم للتخلص من
داعش الامريكان بيطلع بيضرب له ضربتين
ثلاثه وبياخذ تمانى من العراقيين والخليج
وهي هي بالنسبه ما بس اسالك سؤال ما رايك
بالجهاد انت ما رايك بالجهاد المقدس ضد ضد
الجهاد المقدس ضد شو انا جهاد المقد لا
الجهاد المقدس بشكل عام الجهاد الاسلامي
المقدس ضد من يا اخي الجهاد المقد انت مع
ولا ضده في معاير بس بدي اسالك سؤال
باختصار انت الوقت انته الوقت لماذا عندما
يرفع المسلمون السنه الجهاد يصبحون
ارهابيين والجهادي ارها وكذا اليوم حزب
الله يشيع كل قتلاه في سوريا الذين قضوا
في اداء واجبهم الجهادي المقدس لماذا ما
حدا بيحكي عنه هذا لي مش بس حدا جهادي سني
لو الجهاد الكفائي في العراق مثلا نحن
بحياتنا ما رح نقدر نرجع ل مناطقنا
بحياتنا تفجرت بيوتنا انذبح انذبح اولادنا
اولاد عمنا ذبحوا ارتكبت مجازر اليوم هذه
المناطق لا تتمتع لا ببنيه تحتيه ولا
خدمات ولا اي شيء لولا هذا الجهاد الكفائي
لولا الحشد الشعبي والجيش والشرطه نحن ما
كنا قدرنا نرجع لمناطق ابدا جم انته الوقت
انا اسالك اخر سؤال انت تحاول ان تقزم
القضيه انت تحاول ان تعطي الانطباع بانه
تحاول ان تضخم من جرائم نظام يواجه اكثر
من 100 فصيل اجرامي على الارض السوريه ومن
حقه ان يدافع عن ارضه وعن شعبه وعن نظامه
حتى من حقه كل الانظمه تدافع عن نفسها
بينما تتغاضى عن حقيقه مهمه جدا هل تعلم
ان هذا التنظيم الخطير الارها
الذي يسميه الكثيرون ارهابيا يسيطر الان
على مساحه تفوق مساحه سوريا بمره وشوي مره
وربع صارت طيب لماذا لا تريد من العالم ان
يتاهب انظر الجميع يخاف من هذا التنظيم
هناك اجماع دولي على خطوره هذا التنظيم
بينما يعني العالم ليس ليس كما تقول ذا
وجهين او ذو وجهين غير صحيح العالم يعرف
اين الخطر والخطر يكمن في هذا التنظيم
الداعشي باختصار اوباما قال يعني قالها
اوباما عن طريق مدير مخابراته نحن اخطانا
في تقدير موضوع داعش ولكن هم يريدون تمرير
صفقه سياسيه حتى يركعون السنه في سوريا
ويقبلون باعاده تعويم نظام الاسد المجرم
ولا تعويم لنظام الاسد المجرم ولكن اسمح
ليد ال الاخيره دكتور اولا انا انا بحب بس
وجه رساله اخر شيء اخر شيء للسنه والشيعه
لا يمثل السنه وجهه نظر البغدادي وحلفاء
البغدادي هذول لا يمثلون السنه نهائيه
امص نحن والشيعه اخوه الوتار الطائفي نحن
كسنه من يمثل السنه وجهه نظري مو وجه نظر
وع السنه ان يعرفوا ايضا انه كمان اللي عم
يسمعوه
بالتلفزيون للاسف انتهى الوقت التصويت من
الذي يستحق العقاب والملاحقه الدوليه
النظام السوري ام تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
97.1 يستحقها النظام السوري 2 تس يستحقها
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه لم يبقى لنا الا
نشكر ضيفين السيد يزن مشعان الجبوري
والسيد تائر ناشر نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء
المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين هاو فيصل قاسم
يحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء يعطيكم
[موسيقى]
العافيه